welcome to um
the stanford ee uh 380
colloquium on computer systems
um
today uh our speaker is dave rosenthal
who has spoken in
several other times for us
and today he's going to talk about can
we mitigate the externalities of
cryptocurrencies
uh in the run-up to the talk uh dave
said well do i need to introduce myself
or not
and um i think he probably does he knows
more about what's going on
these days than virtually anybody so
dave i'm going to let you take it from
here uh and uh
you can
respond to questions if we get them and
uh i'll uh see you at the other end okay
hey thank you
uh so i apologize if this talks a bit
rough because dennis mailed me yesterday
morning asking if i could speak
so i updated a talk i gave in december
to an institutional investor conference
you don't need to take notes the text of
this talk with links to the sources and
much additional material will be on
blog.dshr.org
i'm aiming to talk for 30 minutes which
i realize is a bit short but that's how
long the talk i updated was
and
be controversial enough to spark a
discussion afterwards so please hold
questions until i'm done
so i'm david rosenthal i work with james
gosling on cmu's andrew project in the
early 80s i was a de with him at sun
later in the 80s working on window
systems including x and file systems
i quit to be employee number four at
nvidia
where curtis preem and i did the beta's
basic io architecture
and then was an early employee at
vitriol which was the second company of
some founders of tibco
before i start talking about
cryptocurrencies i should stress that i
hold no long or short positions in
cryptocurrencies they're derivatives or
related companies i am long in video
unlike most people discussing them i'm
not talking my book
so cryptocurrency's roots lie deep in
the libertarian culture of silicon
valley and the cypherpunks
libertarianism's attraction is based on
ignoring externalities and
cryptocurrencies are no exception
uh bitcoin is notorious for consuming as
much electricity as the netherlands but
there are around 10 000 other
cryptocurrencies most using similar
infrastructure and thus also in
aggregate consuming unsustainable
amounts of electricity
bitcoin alone generates as much e-waste
as the netherlands
cryptocurrencies suffer an epidemic of
pump and dump schemes and wash trading
they enable a 5.2 billion a year
ransomware industry
they have disrupted supply chains for
gpus hard disks ssds and other chips
they've made it impossible for web
services to offer free tiers and they're
responsible for a massive crime wave
including fraud theft tax evasion
funding of rogue states such as north
korea drug smuggling and even as
documented by jameson lop's list of
physical attacks
armed robbery kidnapping torture and
murder
the attempt to force
el salvador's
uh population to use cryptocurrency is a
fiasco
they offer no social benefit beyond
speculation
igor makarov and antoinette shaw write
90 of the transaction volume on the
bitcoin blockchain is not tied to
economically meaningful activities but
is the byproduct of the bitcoin protocol
design as well as the preference of many
participants for anonymity
exchanges play a central role in the
bitcoin system they explain 75
of real bitcoin volume
our results do not support the idea that
the high valuation of cryptocurrencies
is based on the demand for illegal
transactions instead they suggest that
the majority of bitcoin transactions is
linked to speculation
uh bitcoin is only processing around 27
000 economically meaningful transactions
a day
and 75 percent of those are transactions
between exchanges so only two and a half
percent of the transactions are real
blockchain based transfers involving
individuals that's less than five a
minute
nakamoto's motivation for bitcoin was
distrust of institutions especially
central banks
when it launched in the early stage of
the global financial crisis this has had
resonance
the key to a system that involves less
trust is decentralization
so why do suspension bridges have
stranded cables not
solid rods
the major reason is that solid rods
would fail suddenly and catastrophically
whereas stranded cables fail slowly and
make alarming noises while they do
we build software systems out of solid
rods they fail abruptly and completely
most are designed to perform their tasks
as fast as possible so when they're
compromised they perform the attackers
tasks as fast as possible
changing this
making systems that are resilient
ductile like copper not brittle like
glass is an extraordinarily difficult
problem in software engineering
paul vixie pointed out that rate limits
are an essential part of the solution
i got interested in it when burnt out
after three startups all of which ipo i
started work at the stanford library on
the problem of keeping digital
information safe for the long term
this work won my stanford cs co-authors
petros maniatis member rusopoulos tj
julie and professor mary baker and i a
best paper award at the 2003 sosp
for a decentralized consensus system
using proof-of-work
when five years later satoshi nakamoto
published the bitcoin protocol a
cryptocurrency based on a decentralized
consensus mechanism using proof of work
i was naturally interested in how it
turned out
decentralization is unnecessary but
insufficient requirement for system
resilience
centralized systems have a single locus
of control
subverted and the system is at your
mercy
it only took six years for bitcoin to
fail nakamoto's goal of decentralization
with one mining pool controlling more
than half the mining power
in the seven years since no more than
five pol pools have always controlled a
majority of the mining power
uh in 2014 i wrote economies of scale in
peer-to-peer networks explaining the
economic cause of this failure briefly
this is an example of the phenomenon
described by w brian arthur in 1994 as
increasing returns and path dependence
in the economy
information technologies have strong
economies of scale so the larger the
miner the lower the cost and thus the
greater their profit and thus the
greater their market share
blockchain
is unfortunately a term used to describe
two completely different technologies
which have in common only that they both
use a merkle tree data structure
permission block chains have a central
authority controlling
which network knows can add blocks to
the chain
and are thus not decentralized whereas
permissionless blockchains such as
bitcoins do not
this difference is fundamental
permissioned blockchains can use
well-established and relatively
efficient techniques such as byzantine
fault tolerance and thus don't have
significant carbon footprints
these techniques ensure that each node
in the network has performed the same
computation on the same data to arrive
at the same state for the next block in
the chain
this is a consensus mechanism
in principle each node in a
permissionless blockchain's network can
perform a different computation on
different data to arrive at a different
state for the next block in the chain
which of these blocks ends up in the
chain is determined by a randomized
biased election mechanism
for example in proof of workbook chains
such as bitcoins a node wins election by
being the first to solve a puzzle
the length of time it takes to solve the
puzzle is random but the probability of
being first is biased it's proportional
to the compute power the node uses
initially because of network licenses
nodes may disagree as to the next block
in the chain but eventually it will
become clear which block gained the most
acceptance among the nodes
this is why a bitcoin transaction should
not be regarded as final until it is six
blocks from there
discussing
blockchains and their externalities
without specifying permissionless or
permissioned is meaningless they're
completely different technologies
one is 30 years old
the other is 13 years old
because there is no central authority
controlling who can participate
decentralized consensus systems must
defend against civil attacks in which
the attacker creates a majority of
seemingly independent participants which
is secretly under his control
the defense is
to ensure that the reward for a
successful civil attack is less than the
cost of mounting it
thus participation in a permissionless
blockchain must be expensive
so miners must be reimbursed for their
costly efforts
there is no central authority capable of
collecting funds from users and
distributing them to the miners in
proportion to these efforts
thus miners reimbursement must be
generated organically by the blockchain
itself a permissionless blockchain needs
a cryptocurrency to be secure
because
miners opex and capex costs cannot be
paid in the blockchain's cryptocurrency
exchanges are required to enable the
rewards for mining to be converted into
fiat currency to pay these costs
someone needs to be on the other side of
these sell orders
the only reason to be on the buy side of
these orders is the belief that number
go up
thus exchanges need to attract
speculators in order to perform their
function
thus a permissionless blockchain
requires a cryptocurrency to function
and this cryptocurrency requires
speculation to function
uh why are economies of scale a
fundamental problem for decentralized
systems
participation must be expensive
and so will be subject to economies of
scale
they will drive the system to centralize
so the expenditure in attempting to
ensure that the system is decentralized
is a futile waste
most cryptocurrencies impose these costs
as our earlier system did using proof of
work
it was a brilliant idea when cynthia
torque and moni nara
originated
in 1992 being both simple and effective
but when it's required to make
participation expensive enough for a
trillion dollar cryptocurrency it has an
unsustainable carbon footprint
the leading source for estimating
bitcoin's electricity consumption is the
cambridge bitcoin energy consumption
index whose current central estimate is
117 terawatt hours a year
adjusting christian stole at ours 2018
estimate of bitcoin's carbon footprint
to the current cbeci estimate gives a
range of about 40.4 to
125.7 megatons of co2 per year for
bitcoin's opex emissions or between
portugal and myanmar
unfortunately this is likely to be a
considerable underestimate
bitcoin's growing e-waste problem by
alex de breeze and christian still
concludes that bitcoin's annual e-waste
generation adds up to 30.7 metric
kilotons as of may 2021.
this level is comparable to the small
i.t equipment waste produced by a
country such as the netherlands
that is an average of one whole macbook
air of e-waste per economically
meaningful transaction
the reason for this extraordinary waste
is that the profitability of mining
depends on the energy consumed per hash
and the rapid development of mining
asics means
that they rapidly become uncompetitive
the recent stole estimate that the
average service life
is
less than 16 months
this mountain of e-waste contains
embedded carbon emissions from its
manufacture transport and disposal
these graphs show that for facebook and
google data centers capex emissions are
at least as great as the op exhibitions
cryptocurrencies assume that society is
committed to this waste of
energy and hardware forever
their response is
frantic greenwashing
such as claiming that because bitcoin
mining allows an obsolete uncompetitive
coal burning plant near saint louis to
continue burning coal it's somehow good
for the environment
but they argue
mining can use renewable energy first at
present it doesn't
for example lux folio implemented their
commitment to 100 renewable energy by
buying 15 megawatts of coal-fired power
from the navajo nation
secondly even if it were true that
cryptocurrencies ran on renewable power
the idea that it's okay for speculation
to waste vast amounts of renewable power
assumes that doing so doesn't compete
with more socially valuable uses for own
renewables or indeed for power in
general
right now the world is short of power
one major reason that china banned
cryptocurrency mining was that they
needed their limited supplies of power
to keep factories running and homes warm
shortage of energy is not a short-term
problem
this graph is from peak oil and the low
carbon energy transition a net energy
perspective by lewis de illinois at hell
showing that as the early easiest
deposits are exploited first the energy
return on investment
measuring the fraction of the total
energy
delivered to consumers decreases
de la noire dell's figure one shows the
gross and net oil energy history and
projects it to 2050.
the growth energy and thus the carbon
emission peaks around 2035 but because
the energy used in extraction the top
yellow band increases rapidly the net
energy peaks in about five years
this is a problem for two reasons if
society is to survive carbon emissions
need to start decreasing now
not in a decade and a half
and renewables need to be deployed very
rapidly
deploying renewables consumes energy
which is paid back during their initial
operation
thus the current transition to renewable
power consumes energy reducing that
available for other uses
the world cannot afford to waste a
netherlands worth of energy on
speculation that could instead be
deploying renewables
if cryptocurrency speculation is to
continue it needs to vastly reduce its
carbon footprint by eliminating proof of
work
the two major candidates are proof of
space and time
and proof of stake
proof of stake in time attempts to make
participation expensive by wasting
storage instead of computation
the highest profile of such effort is
bram cohen's chia which he described in
a 2018 ee380
it's funded by andreessen horowitz the
softbank of crypto
uh chia's space farmers create and store
plots consisting of large amounts of
otherwise useless data
the software is ingenious but the design
suffered from neovite about storage
media and markets
when it launched in may gullible farmers
rushed to buy hard disks and ssds by
july the capital tied up in farming
hardware was around six times the market
cap of the chia coin
cheers ceo described the result
we've kind of destroyed the short-term
dis supply chain
disc vendors were forced to explain that
chia farming voided the media's warranty
just as with gpus the used market was
flooded with burnt out storage
chia's coin initially traded at 1 934
before dropping more than 90 percent
last i looked it was 81
i expect a16z made money but everyone
else had to deal with the costs
chia doesn't use much electricity more
to do with failure than with the
technology but it does have a major
e-waste problem
the costs that proof-of-stake imposes to
make participation expensive are the
risk of loss and the foregone liquidity
of the stake
an escrow amount of the cryptocurrency
itself
this has two philosophical problems
it isn't just that the genie coefficient
of cryptocurrencies are extremely high
but the proof of stake makes this a
self-reinforcing problem
because the rewards for mining new
blocks and the fees for including
transactions in blocks
flow to the holders in proportion to
their holdings
whatever genie coefficient the systems
start out with will always increase
proof of stake isn't effective at
decentralization
and cryptocurrency whales are believers
in number go up
the eventual progress of their coin to
the moon
means that the temporary costs of
staking are irrelevant
there are also a host of severe
technical problems the accomplished
ethereum team have been making a
praiseworthy effort
to overcome them for more than seven
years and are still more than a year
away from being able to mitigate
migrate off proof of work
uh
but vitalik bhutarin pointed out that
lack of decentralization was a security
risk in 2017 and this was amply borne
out last year when justin sun conspired
with three exchanges staking their
customers coins to take over the steam
proof of state blockchain
pushing back against the economic forces
centralizing these systems is extremely
difficult
the advantage of commissioners over
permissioned blockchains is claimed to
be decentralization how has that worked
out in practice
as has been
true for the last seven years no more
than five mining pools control the
majority of the bitcoin mining power and
last november two polls controlled the
majority of ethereum mining
makarov and sure right
six out of the largest mining pools are
registered in china and have strong ties
to bitmain technologies which is the
largest producer of bitcoin mining
hardware
it isn't just the mining pools that are
centralized the top 10 of miners control
90
and just a tenth of a percent about 50
miners control close to 50 of mining
capacity
this centralization doesn't just
increase the system's technical risk but
also its legal risk
the reason is that in almost all
cryptocurrencies a transaction wishing
to be confirmed is submitted to a public
mempool of pending transactions
the mining pools choose transactions
from there to include in the blocks they
attempt to mine
this as nicholas weaver points out means
that mining pools are providing money
transmission services under u.s law
thus in the u.s they are required to
follow the anti-money laundering know
your customer
aml kyc rules as enforced by the
financial crimes enforcement network
the only pool to try following them stop
doing this because the larger bitcoin
community objects to the idea or
attempting to restrict bitcoin to legal
uses
as adam fa against sir edel pointed out
a byzantine quorum system of size 20
could achieve better decentralization
than proof-of-work mining at a much
lower resource cost
thus the only reason for the massive
carbon footprint of proof of work and
the complexity and risk of the
alternatives is to maintain the illusion
of decentralization
alas it's unlikely that any alternative
defense against civil attacks will be
widely enough adopted to mitigate proof
of works carbon emissions
immutability is one of the two things
that make the cryptocurrency crime wave
so effective
these systems are brittle make a single
momentary mistake and your assets are
irresistible
immutability sounds like a great idea
when everything's going to plan but in
the real world mistakes are inevitable
let's take a few recent examples
the 23 million dollar fee bitfinex paid
for a hundred thousand dollar
transaction
or the 19 million dollar oopsie at
indexed finance or the 31 million oopsie
at monox or the 90 million dollar ops
oopsie compound and the subsequent 67
million dollar oopsie all of which left
the perpetrators pleading with the
beneficiaries to return the loop
and in compounds case threatening its
customers with the ultimate crypto
punishment reporting them to the irs
12 billion dollars in d5 theft so far or
about
five percent of all the funds
vulnerabilities are equally inevitable
as we see with the 38 million dollar 19
million dollar and 130 million dollar
hacks of cream finance last year the 115
million dollar hack of badger dao the
196 million dollar hack of bitmark the
recent
323 million dollar hack of wormhole and
of course the 600 million dollar hack of
poly network
uh because ethereum and similar
cryptocurrencies are programming
environments their attack surface is
much larger than bitcoins
now that d fire and nft protocols are
implemented as smart contracts in these
environments the attack surface has
expanded much further
one example is the rash of hacks
involving hijacks of the discord servers
of the communities surrounding them to
lure victims into authenticating their
wallets to malign smart contracts
another is the flood of rug pools buried
in the smart contracts implementing nfts
yet another is described in dang
within's
how 323 million dollars in crypto was
stolen from a blockchain bridge called
wormhole because there are many
competing blockchains
bridges exist to provide liquidity
between them
last month vitalik praterin provided a
detailed explanation of why they are a
fundamental security problem a smart
contract called the guardian
locks up coins on one blockchain and
unlocks the same number on another
but in this case the guardian failed to
properly validate signatures
three days later a bug in another bridge
was exploited for another 4.3 million
dollars
the centralization of ethereum's mining
pools and exchanges enabled poly network
to persuade them to blacklist the
addresses involved
this made it very difficult for the
miscreant to
escape with the loop much of which was
returned
but it also
uh
vividly demonstrated that in most block
trains it's the mining pools that decide
which transaction to make it into a
block and are thus executed
the small number of dominant mining
pools can effectively prevent addresses
from transacting and
prioritize transactions from favored
addresses they can also allow
transactions to avoid the public mempool
to prevent them being front run by bots
this turned out to be useful when a
small group of white hats discovered a
vulnerability in a smart contract
holding 9.6 million dollars
the key point of escaping the dark
forest samsung's account of their
night's work is that after the group
spotted the vulnerability and built a
transaction to rescue the funds they
could not put the rescue transaction in
the public mempool because it would have
been front run by a bot
they had to find a miner who would put
the transaction in a block without it
appearing in the mempool
in other words their transaction needed
a dark pool
and they had to trust the compar
cooperative miner not to front run it
ethereum is fortunately very far from
decentralized being centralized around a
small number of large pools thus the
group needed trusted pool not an
individual miner
at the time the three largest pools
mined more than half the blocks between
them so only three cores would have been
needed to have a very good chance that
the transaction would appear in one of
the next few blocks
most activity in
quote trustless unquote cryptocurrencies
actually uses trusted third parties
exchanges that are layered above the
blockchain itself
these use conventional web-based
identities and provide another layer of
centralization
binance the dominant exchange does two
out of every three derivative
transactions and half of all the spot
transactions
adam leviton points out that customers
are unsecured creditors of exchanges
exchanges are
routinely compromised in most cases
immutability means the perfect funds are
not recovered
but more fundamentally the entire
cryptocurrency ecosystem depends upon a
trusted third party
tether which acts as a central bank
issuing the stable coins that currencies
are priced in
and
priced against and traded in
this is despite the fact that tether is
known to be untrustworthy having
consistently lied about its re reserves
the other main enabler of the
cryptocurrency crime spree is the
prospect of transactions that aren't
merely immutable but are also anonymous
anonymity for small transactions is
important but for large transactions it
provides the infrastructure for major
crime in the physical world cash is
anonymous but it has the valuable
property that the cost and difficulty of
transacting increase strongly with sides
kyc aml and other regulations leverage
this
cryptocurrencies lack this property the
ease with which current cryptocurrency
can be transferred between institutions
that do and do not observe the kyc aml
regulations means that absent robust
action by the u.s the kyc aml regime is
doomed
the most serious crime enabled by
anonymity is ransomware which is
regularly crippling essential
infrastructure such as oil pipelines and
hospital systems
to say nothing about losses to
businesses large and small
this business is estimated to gross 5.2
billion a year and is growing rapidly
aided by a network of specialist service
providers
that's just the ransom payments the
actual externalities include the much
larger costs of recovering from the
attacks
there are cryptocurrencies that provide
almost complete anonymity using
sophisticated cryptography for example
monero
observers cannot decipher addresses
trading monero transaction amounts
address balances or transaction
histories
bitcoin and similar
cryptocurrencies are pseudonymous
not anonymous anyone can create and use
an essentially unlimited number of
pseudonyms addresses
but transactions and balances using the
republic
a newly minted pseudonym cannot be
de-anonymized but as it becomes enmeshed
in the public web of transactions
maintaining anonymity takes more
operational security than most users can
manage
users are aware of the risk that their
transactions can be traced so many
engage in wash transactions between
addresses they control and use mixers
and tumblers to mingle their coins with
those of other miscreants
because it's almost impossible to
actually buy legal goods with bitcoin
at some point a holder needs to use an
exchange to obtain fiat currency
this risks having their identity
connected into the web of transactions
on the blockchain
uh macro of ensure conclude 90 of the
transaction volume on the big coin
blockchain
is not tied to economically meaningful
activity but is the byproduct of the
bitcoin protocol design as well as the
preference of many participants for
anonymity in other words 90
of bitcoins carbon footprint is used in
a partially successful attempt to
compensate for its deficient anonymity
because there are existing alternatives
such as monero that provide greatly
increased anonymity attempts to mitigate
the externalities of pseudonymous
cryptocurrencies are likely to be
self-defeating
as the ransomware industry shows
users will migrate to these alternatives
reducing the effectiveness of chain
analysis
although the techniques used to
implement decentralization are effective
in theory at scale emergency economic
effects render them ineffective
despite this decentralization is
fundamental to the cryptocurrency
ideology making mitigation of its
externalities effectively impossible
and
attempts to mitigate the externalities
of pseudonymous cryptocurrencies are
likely to be self-defeating
we can conclude first permission
blockchains do not need a cryptocurrency
to defend against civil attacks and thus
do not have significant externalities
permissionless blockchains require a
cryptocurrency and doesn't necessarily
impose all the externalities i've
described except the carbon footprint
if successful permissionless blockchains
using proof of work or any other way to
waste a real resource as a civil defense
have unacceptable carbon footprints
whatever civil defense they use
economics forces successful
permissionless blockchains to centralize
there is no justification
for wasting resources in a doomed
attempt at decentralization
don't get me wrong i'm not a fan of
centralization i started building a
decentralized permission this system
almost a quarter century ago
it would be wonderful if we could figure
out how to build a web that would resist
centralization
but all the technical and financial
cleverness that's been poured into
cryptocurrencies hasn't succeeded in
doing that
why
it's because it isn't about the
technology
i'm a big believer in bill joy's law of
startups success is inversely
proportional to the amount of money you
have
for two and a half million dollars we
got nvidia to working silicon that was
revolutionary in two different respects
right now there is way too much money
if a system is to be decentralized it
has to have a low barrier to entry
if it has a low barrier to entry
competition will ensure that it has low
margins
low margin businesses don't attract
venture capital
vcs are pouring money into
cryptocurrency and web 3 companies
this money is not going to build systems
with low barriers to entry and thus low
margins
thus the systems that will result from
this moment flight of money will not be
decentralized no matter what the sales
pitch says
despite all the cleverness and hype the
technology just isn't that good
it's both extraordinarily inefficient
and extraordinarily insecure
nicholas weaver points out that the
ethereum computer is one five thousandth
as powerful as a raspberry pi
and for the cost of one second of its
use you can buy nearly 60 raspberry pi's
moxie marlinspang
exploits the fact that an nft is a link
to a file of metadata that links to the
image it purports to
represent
so neither is guaranteed to exist or be
valid
you have only to glance at molly white's
web free is going just great timeline to
wonder why anyone thinks this wretched
hive of scum and villainy should be the
future of the web
i hope i've said enough
to start some discussion i think there
are three basic lines of argument
you could argue that the externalities i
described don't exist you'll have a hard
time proving that the waste of
electricity and hardware and the crime
wave are imaginary
you could argue that although the
externalities do exist the benefits of
decentralization outweigh them
the problem here is that since the
systems are not actually decentralized
we get the externalities but don't get
the benefits
or you could argue that although the
externalities do exist and the systems
aren't decentralized they're making so
much money that we shouldn't worry
the problem here is that the amount of
actual money
you can get out of a cryptocurrency
equals the amount of actual money that
has been put in
minus the actual cost of mining
so the big picture is that although
there may be winners in aggregate the
system loses money
so that's my
brief talk
and let's uh have some discussion
yeah so um
mark miller and a company he helped
found called agorik
has made the point that these um
uh cryptocurrencies
form a machine that can't be corrupted
the way our the hardware over individual
machines can be
no supply chain attacks no
you know
hardware attacks like
row hammer and things like that and so
they now have albeit a very slow
they have a an incorruptable machine
what's your comment on that well i think
that's bull
uh firstly these things all run the same
software
so you can have a mount a software
supply chain attack against them
and
building a computer
that runs one five thousandth as fast as
a raspberry pi uh
it's not a great help to the world
okay so it's impossible for services to
create a free tier anything that
anything that
on the web that's accessible that's free
that can run a program will be exploited
to mine cryptocurrencies
javascript anything
uh
yes i know and if i'm aware of the
uh
the ethereum um r d discord i don't
track it closely um
the the history is that that um the
timeline for
ethereum to migrate to proof of stake
has consistently um slipped
and uh their predictions that it's a
year away uh have always
been delayed now it's true that they do
actually have the the uh
the test
um
blockchain running
and but they haven't finished the
software
and uh the part that they haven't
finished looks to me to be one of the
most difficult parts but in any case
proof of stake is just a way of making
sure that a system is controlled by a
small number of insiders
and so i don't uh
i i
i just don't think it's a good idea
and
what we see with it with ethereum and
similar
programming environments is that they
are um
a magnet for crime
because it sounds like you have
pervasive problems with the governance
models of cryptocurrencies well
yes
the whole
pitch is that these things are
these things are decentralized and
democratic and controlled by their
community
and so on and that is in practice just
not true
um because
right i mean
yes
says the the code is the law unless one
of the key stakeholders ox was gored
well yes we've seen that um several
times notice most notably with uh the
ethereum for uh after the dao um was
exploited uh but actually it's um
there are there are several examples um
oh and and as a regards proof of stake i
i think that the the steam example is um
is worth noticing uh exchanges
typically
are allowed to stake their their
customers coins this is certainly true
for coinbase
uh
and
i'm pretty sure it's
true for binance
and what that means is that essentially
uh
binance and
a small number of other exchanges
uh can outvote anybody on on
proof-of-state blockchains
unless the somehow the um
the
ability to uh state their customers
coins is taken away
uh yes proof of stake is difficult
uh
yeah i mean i i
i have to hand it to to the ethereum
people they they have been taking a very
very serious
uh approach to trying to implement
proof of stake properly and
um
uh the fact that it's taken them seven
years and they're not done is an
illustration of just how hard it is
and
one might think
that
uh
[Music]
basing
the
the second largest cryptocurrency on
a technology that is that hard to get
right
uh would be rather a big risk
uh
okay so uh what do i think of filecoin
and ipfs
well um
i'm very skeptical i i i wrote about
this
a long time ago i'm very skeptical about
the
um economics of uh file coin
um ipfs
is uh i mean
a
a decentralized
uh
a decentralized content address file
system is a great idea
uh
but uh
people
don't understand
uh
how ipfs
works they assume that if you
put something into ipfs it's out there
forever
but actually it isn't unless you pay
rent to a pinning service to keep a copy
of it somewhere on ipfs because
otherwise it will eventually get
kicked out of the caches uh yes dfinity
has a consensus mechanism that randomly
chooses a subset to vote on
for the next block yep uh so does
avalanche and i think that's a great
idea
because
that's one of the ideas behind the the
uh the lots protocol
uh
randomly choosing a subset of your uh
electorate to vote
definitely makes it much harder for the
uh attacker to uh attack the system
um because they need to guess right
about what the subset of
of the uh electorate is
and
uh
for details about why this is a great
idea you can look at our sosp paper or
the expanded version that was in
transactions on computing systems
i i'm i'm working on a a blog post about
avalanche uh
which is mostly about why
randomization
is a good idea it it um randomization it
it's
so people tend to think that because
byzantine fault tolerance is one of the
really strong results in cs
that uh
uh
that fault tolerance is um
is is a a uh
a determinant
situation but it's not uh what byzantine
fault tolerance says is that the
system's okay unless you have uh if you
have three f plus one replicas the
system's okay unless you have
uh more than f
um
on their failures
and
uh the question is what's the
probability that the system in the real
world
will encounter more than
failures so it's probabilistic and so is
um
and and
so is the kind of
um
the the kind of consensus system behind
uh locks and avalanche and dfinity
okay
what else dave do you think we're we're
we're working on the right problem here
uh
you know we we use the coin structure
and uh
currency to uh
to do stuff other than uh
transfer money around presumably
uh maybe there's a better way to do the
thing that we need as opposed to the way
we're doing it
okay so i mean the question i'd ask is
what's the problem you're trying to
solve
typically getting there yeah and and
typically
the answer that you get from the
um
from the cryptocurrency world uh
or the decentralized systems world is
that they're trying to deal with the
fact that
the web we have is dominated by a small
number of large companies
and what we see is that systems based
around cryptocurrencies are dominated by
a small number of large companies
so
if that was the
problem you're trying to solve you have
definitively failed
uh now possibly there was some other
problem you were trying to solve
that you just didn't tell me about but
the one you told me about you have
failed to solve
and this isn't
this isn't something new you failed to
solve it
seven years ago
and
uh despite all the gaslighting since you
haven't succeeded in recovering from
that failure
[Music]
so
you see the blockchain is something
better than a totally distributed
uh
mechanism for
[Music]
taking a series of events and applying a
partial ordering to them
so
the
federal reserve and mit have a project
called project hamilton
which is
uh
building the infrastructure for central
banking
you know uh cryptocurrencies
stable coins
and
they've just released a report which
says that one of their two prototype
systems
has managed has sustained
uh
1.7 million transactions a second
with finality in less than two seconds
uh and
has done that
despite
two of its data centers failing
simultaneously
uh so centralized and blockchain-based
systems permission blockchain based
systems can be extremely powerful
decentralized ones cannot be
uh extremely powerful because they have
the overhead of
of
defending against civil attacks
[Music]
and and they have a much worse
synchronization problem
well i i was called upon the um
to look at uh
nfts a little bit a while back
and i really would appreciate it if you
tell us tell me a little bit about it uh
i don't see any value to them
so
an nft is a smart contract on one of
these programmable
blockchains
typically ethereum or solana
and
it is it arranges that there's only one
instance of it
uh
and
but because it's extremely expensive
to
um take up a lot of space
in in blockchain you can't actually put
the image
uh that your or whatever it is that
you're nft
into the blockchain itself what's in the
blockchain
is a link
which is typically a link to a
a
file full of metadata a small file full
of metadata
it's a url for this small file full of
metadata and in the file full of
metadata is a link to the actual image
which is also a url
so i i spent nearly two decades working
on web archiving
and one of the very first observations
about the dynamic behavior of the web at
scale was that uh urls um go404 link rot
and
subsequent research showed that they
also
suffer from contact content drift in
other words the same url resolves at a
later time to different content
and
nfts have both of those problems
now you can mitigate
uh
them by ensuring that both the meta data
file
and the image itself are in for example
ipv ipfs
but if you do that you have to keep
paying rent
uh in order to maintain this these files
in ipfs uh
and
um
this isn't really
what people think of when they think of
nfts
and uh
what is why why do does an nft command
such a very high price when it offers no
uh value
uh
well because the the world is full of
scammers
basically
but the i i
the people who thought up the idea of
nfts were were artists and they thought
up this idea
hoping with with the goal
of uh
of
getting more of the value of their work
to artists
but because this thing is based on
cryptocurrencies what they ended up
doing was enabling scammers
and what we see at the moment for
example is that there are bots going
around and scraping collections of
images and minting uh nfts for them
completely without permission from the
the uh
the artists who created the images um
and uh it's down to the artists
to complain about this to open sea and
have open sea which is the centralized
market for these things blacklist them
uh
and so instead of uh
i mean
the other the other thing is the you you
you mention
the very high values put on these things
uh one of the interesting things about
the entire cryptocurrency world is that
almost every single number
describing it is wildly exaggerated
we saw in my talk that the transaction
rate is wildly exaggerated
uh the market cap of uh cryptocurrencies
is wildly exaggerated because um
you can't get that much money out
if you did
you would crash the value and we saw
that was about six months ago uh
someone
crashed the value of bitcoin 10 by
selling 150 of them
[Laughter]
and
what else i mean the values of nfts are
entirely uh due to the fact that almost
every nft is what traded
uh
we have
today we had the wonderful example of um
uh ivanka trump's uh
uh nfts was it anchor on milan millennia
i can't remember anyway um
uh i think it was melania anyway the the
uh
they had a nft of her hat
uh an image of her hat which
they wanted to sell for a quarter of a
million bucks but
uh they launched the sale while the
value of the cryptocurrencies was going
down and
somebody took a look at the blockchain
and worked out that what had happened
was that they had given uh
uh
whatever it was a hundred and
one thousand eight hundred
uh souls
from the salona
blockchain to somebody
who bought the nft
and then the money went right back where
it came from
uh
which is a little suspicious
and i i have a blog post about somebody
who wash traded a uh
a an nft
for a half a billion dollars
and
could do this because of the d5
they could do a flash loan
where you borrow
uh cryptocurrency
and do something and then pay the
cryptocurrency back and all of that is
bundled into a single transaction
uh and sure you pay you paid a little
bit of money uh
for for the interest for this fraction
of a second but you have it um so they
borrowed half a billion dollars uh wash
traded and nft paid the half a billion
dollars back and then lifted listed the
nft for over a billion dollars
uh
these numbers are just um completely
incredible
um
quite agree
are there other questions out there
um
i'm sorry that that my talk was
considerably shorter than the typical
e380 one but it was that
it was
the result of hurried up dating of a
talk which had a hard half hour limit on
it
and i didn't have time to expand it all
that much
um
and as i say uh
like it was an awesome talk and paul's
right
like also it was an awesome talk like
all my talks it'll be up on
blog.dshr.org
um so you can follow the links and and
get the sources for all my outrageous
claims
but
uh
yes
the wash trading nft one if you look on
my if you look on my well uh if you if
you look on my blog for a post called
number go up uh making sure that numbers
go up you'll find that the story of the
half billion dollar um nft
and
uh
i i gotta say
this
being skeptical about this world is
really a whole lot of fun oh and if you
if you want to have more uh about this
the
the economist
has a podcast called babbage about
technology
and the one that they just put up
features a number of luminaries
um
uh like uh tim o'reilly and so on
and me
uh
talking about web3
and the first part of this podcast is a
whole lot of web3 people
emitting this awesome
tsunami of hype
about what what web 3 is going to do for
the world
which of course all happens because it's
decentralized and then it has
um tim
and me and some economist editors
pouring cold water on this
so
you'll find that in the comments on my
uh on on my blog but you can just look
for
economist babbage and you'll find the
podcast
okay
yeah
well
thanks so much for the invitation to do
this i
i
i find that talking about this stuff is
really fun
it's amazing and uh the the folks out
there on the uh on the comments coming
up on the uh on the screen were just uh
just very useful um i think it's time we
let you go
okay uh sort of that time but thank you
very much and uh
we'll see you uh
see you at the next meeting
you